listening everyone on just one thing
which is what's been happening at our
borders and especially at dover
last night at 11 pm the french
government imposed
restrictions on uk freight crossing to
france
when accompanied by a driver and so
today i chaired a meeting of the
government's emergency
cobra committee in order to coordinate a
uk-wide
response and it's vital first
to stress that these delays which are
only occurring
at dover only affect human
handled freight and that is
only 20 of the total arriving or
departing
arriving from or departing to the
european continent
which means the vast majority of food
medicines and other supplies are coming
and going
as normal you may also be aware in fact
i'd be amazed if you weren't
that the government has been preparing
for a long time
for exactly this kind of event so
working with the kent resilience forum
kent county council on highways england
we've activated our long prepared plans
with the result that we've
already been able to reduce the number
of lorries
waiting on the m20 from 500 to 170
the site at manston airfield is ready to
cope with any
overflow and of course we're working
with our friends across the channel
to unblock the flow of trade as fast as
possible and the government at all
levels
is uh communicating with our friends in
paris i've just spoken to
president macron we had a very uh good
call and we both understand each other's
positions and want
to resolve these problems as fast as
as possible and i know that grant is
also speaking to his
counterpart and we're working to a
solution as i say
as fast as we can to allow freight
traffic to resume between the uk
and france and to ensure that lorries
can travel in both directions
in a covered secure way i once
we in the uk fully understand
the anxieties of our friends about kobe
their anxieties about
the new variant but it's also true that
we believe the risks of transmission by
a solitary driver
sitting alone in the cab are
really very low and so we hope to make
progress
as fast as we possibly can
i want to repeat that these delays only
apply to a very small
percentage of food entering the uk and
as british
supermarkets have said their supply
chains are strong
and robust so everyone can continue
to shop normally and to our
international friends and partners
i want to say very frankly that we
understand
uh your concerns and uh i i hope
everybody can see that as soon as we
were briefed in in
uk government on the the fast
transmissibility
of this new strain at i think 3 15 on
friday afternoon we lodged all the
necessary information with the world
health organization
and we took prompt and decisive
action the very next day to curb
the spread of the new variant within the
the uk and we want to work with our
colleagues with our friends around the
world as we have
from the beginning to develop new
treatments and to develop
new vaccines as we have and i by the way
i can today announce that over
half a million people more than 500 000
people
in the uk have now received their first
dose as we've seen
throughout this pandemic this virus alas
can move all too swiftly from one
nation to another but it is steadily
being defeated by an international
response and
an international response that is
bringing bringing the hope
of vaccines to the entire world and
in that the uk will continue to play
its full part